why is the dick size so
the reason why it's important is because
you girls don't understand
the volume of your [ __ ]
right now you girls are sitting here and
you're both in your head going i got the
tightest [ __ ] because you haven't heard
anybody tell you that your [ __ ] wasn't
tight in your whole life
we
say your pussy's tight because it's a
reflection of our dicks right when we're
going oh your pussy's so tight we're
really going oh my dick is so big
right
so
so
you're
tied into like your tightness is tied
into our ego
right so every girl thinks they have the
same size [ __ ] and it's the tightest
because every girl's been told they have
the tightest [ __ ] when you're at the
gym you're not peeking into each other's
[ __ ] right
so you have no clue everything's
internal guys when we're like [ __ ]
peeing at the airport you might walk and
then there's a guy and he's holding his
[ __ ] you're like yeah
what country is he from right like are
you saying more like because you're so
exposed to other men's penises that it's
on your mind
okay you just see it and it's like at
the gym you see it really it's there
you're just naturally competitive
because it's in it's you see it you see
it and it's in porn you don't see
internally what's going on in there like
their [ __ ] they're like tight and
then they open up on the inside but i
guess what i was trying to get to is
like
dick size you've never seen a little
rugby football
[ __ ]
you can be a better lover yeah
you know and with like the guy with the
not as big dick could have no i want you
to keep saying this live this is
adorable keep going are you serious it's
the motion of the ocean it's not i'm not
saying what it is i'm just saying like
there's it's not that that's not the
end-all be-all because
no it's really not
no
that's been like the worst sex of my
life like the bigger dicks i've had but
you're you're like a tiny thing that's
true you know thank you so that's the
thing so you probably don't need as much
totally fair but a bigger girl she's
gonna need to get filled the [ __ ] off
and let's go right like so
right
right she's gonna need some [ __ ]
campbell's soup
you know
chunky maybe
right so your idea of what it is is
gonna be different and your idea of like
vagina size is gonna be different
yeah i have no concept of vagina size
because i don't care i only have one to
be concerned with yeah well we also have
that but you haven't been told anything
to concern you like no guys in there
like going what the [ __ ] yes but there
are girls have different sized [ __ ]
that's a fact also by the way girls
don't walk around thinking we have the
tightest positions yeah i have given
myself a very fair assessment
i think i'm not like oh god you know i
don't think i have
the grippiest [ __ ] i think i have
strength like my kegels are real strong
and i know how to time it with the
undulation of a man what does that mean
when he thrusts in and out you time when
you squeeze right you squeeze and suck
it's a timing thing if you're just
constantly doing this there's it's
there's strategy involved but i don't
think that i have the tightest person in
the world no i think i just know how to
do it
and that's how i feel that men should
also look at it
because there's no i also but i'm very
anti-body shaming like i don't like
i just don't see a reason to talk about
like dick size and like better or worse
because i've had sex with different
sizes and different people and like it's
not there's not a correlation to the
good time that i had yeah
that makes sense
if the motion was good
is there a size that you would like the
ocean to be i
husband dick
husband husband dick is where
it's at yeah and that might be different
for everyone but husband dick is really
the goal
you might be husband dick for your wife
i hope so
[Applause]